Привет! Это четвёртый урок модуля. В прошлом у нас на FigJam появились Sitemap и Userflow. Это скелет продукта в структурном виде. Теперь тот же скелет мы превратим уже в Lo-Fi Warframe. Берём из Sitemap 3-5 ключевых экранов и собираем для них примитивные макеты в отдельном Figma Design файле.
Следующие уроки будут про неё, как те же Warframe, которые мы соберём сегодня, потом наполнить компонентами, токенами и, ну, в общем-то, оформить в нормальный человеческий вид. Но об этом потом. Сейчас давай разберёмся с Warframe.
Итак, коротко про формат. Для тех, кто не в курсе, давайте на всякий случай затронем эту тему. Warframe — это скелет экрана до готового визуала. Блоки, их расположение, иерархия — такой низкодетализированный прототип, на котором можно глобально разобрать, что мы вообще делаем.
То есть, вместо реальных изображений у нас серые прямоугольники, вместо кнопок в цветах бренда у нас рамки с текстом, вместо фирменной типографики у нас дефолтный системный шрифт.
То есть, мы именно структурно размечаем то, как будут выглядеть наши экраны. Зачем именно Lo-Fi прототипы? Почему мы начинаем с них?
Если дальше в модуле будет дизайн-система, если дальше в модуле будет дизайн-система, если сразу рисовать Hi-Fi, то есть высоко детализированные прототипы, мы застрянем в цветах и
шрифтах еще до того, как стало понятно, как эта вообще структура работает.
Да, когда я провожу какие-нибудь эфиры или видео записываю, это допустимо, потому что мне нужен быстрый результат, который уже не стыдно показать.
Но, если мы говорим о работе над настоящим продуктом, нужно двигаться постепенно, системно, аккуратно и основательно.
Для этого нам и нужны Lo-Fi варфреймы, то есть структурные проблемы на них видны за минуту.
Этот блок не влезет, тут сетей два, один явно лишний, навигация нечитаема и так далее.
Исправить в таком простом макете первой итерации намного проще, чем уже в полноценном собранном Hi-Fi экране.
Ну, схема-то в общем та же, что и в прошлых уроках.
Мы используем директивы, которые я уже для вас собрал.
Давайте разберемся немного, как эта директива выглядит, из чего она состоит.
Делится она также, как и прежде, на два этапа.
Первый это текстовый формат, то есть полное, доскональное описание того, что нам нужно.
Каждый экран, он сначала формирует текстовый вид, запрашивает у тебя Approve.
Перед этим ты вообще выбираешь, какие конкретные экраны у нас пойдут в эту первую итерацию.
Потому что сразу все сейчас делать, у нас горят токены и мы будем сидеть ждать, пока они восстановятся.
Дальше он запросит у тебя под какое устройство, какие размеры должны быть у наших варфреймов.
У тебя скорее всего в перде это уже есть, если нет, то он предположит и предложит.
Ну и в конечном итоге, да, рэкдаун структура каждого экрана, все максимально разбито, структурно, четко.
Ну мы посмотрим, как это работает, я уже эту директиву запускал, разумеется.
Второй этап это уже Canvas, тут по сути от нас ничего не зависит, он делает все самостоятельно, закидывает куда-то экраны, потом перегруппирует их, меняет местами, смотрит, чтобы все было нормально, правит и так далее.
Здесь могут возникнуть артефакты не в плане, наверное, качества его сборки, а в плане того, как он вообще понимает структуру этого проекта.
То есть я, например, присылал ему ссылку на конкретную страницу, в которой нужно разместить.
В 8 из 10 случаев он действительно там это делает.
Вот, в последний раз он это сделал вообще на другой странице, куда-то поверх других экранов поместил.
Короче, такое бывает, руками перенести дело 1 секунды.
На всякий случай отмечу, в прошлый раз мы работали через generate diagram, мы рисовали именно sitemap, userflow, то есть diagram, и он использовал эту команду.
Сейчас же мы будем работать полностью через useFigma.
На всякий случай это отмечу, думаю, это и так понятно, но лучше это закрепить.
Итак, давайте посмотрим, как директива отработала у меня.
Как видишь, тут у меня уже сообщение, что Warframe на конвасе.
Откатимся немного назад и начнем с самого начала.
Как проходит процесс?
То есть, как обычно, эту директиву мы ему закидываем, он начинает работу, не обязательно даже говорить запускай и так далее, он сам прекрасно все поймет.
Он пишет, запускаю директиву Warframe, начинаю с первой фазы, с выбора экранов.
Смотрит по критерию, что у нас точно должно в MVP войти и выдает нам перечень экранов.
Из них мы можем выбрать, какие мы хотим сейчас собрать в первой итерации.
Я взял сразу все четыре.
Тут также он говорит о том, какие он не включил экраны, какие менее значительные.
Из них тоже можно что-нибудь выбрать, если у тебя очень много токенов и ты готов подождать.
Я выбрал четыре экрана.
Все, мы перешли к следующей фазе.
Фаза размера.
Он говорит, что у тебя десктоп веб-приложение.
В PRD сказано, что 1280 на 720 это минимальное разрешение.
Я предлагаю тебе 1440 на 1024.
Я говорю, да, супер, идем дальше.
Вот.
Затем фаза 1.3 это структура экранов.
Он описывает здесь мне каждый экран, что в нем должно быть.
Создает соответствующие файлики.
Тут у нас появляется папочка Warframe.
И здесь их просто дотошное, максимально подробное описание, что на них должно быть.
Ознакомливаемся с этим или нет, если нам лень.
Но, в общем-то, смотрим, что он там насобирал.
И, конечно, результат будет круче, если ты поправишь его в чем-то.
Если, конечно, правки есть.
В общем, увлекаемся в процесс и получаем результат круче.
Я думаю, ты сам это понимаешь.
Итак, первый экран мы так прошли, второй экран прошли, третий экран прошли и так далее.
Например, на одном из экранов у меня были модальные окна, еще какие-то элементы, которые важны для этого экрана.
Поэтому он предложил, мы просто этот экран обзорный оставляем или еще модалки дорисуем.
Я сказал, что дорисуем, поэтому у нас еще три маленьких фрейма появилось в проекте.
В конечном итоге все четыре экрана он собрал.
Каждый из них можно посмотреть.
Вот как раз-таки этот экран, в котором появилось еще три модалки.
Все.
Он спрашивает, все супер, опруем.
Я говорю, да.
И тогда мы можем присылать ссылку на фигму, в которой хотим все это дело разместить.
Как мы это делаем, на всякий случай покажу.
Заходим в свой проект.
Я сюда уже перетянул сайтмэп и юзерфлоу.
И тебе советую это сделать.
Сделать это вообще никаких проблем не составит.
Просто открываем фигджем файлик, нажимаем Ctrl-C.
И благодаря тому, что мы остаемся в инфраструктуре фигмы, можем просто вставить все эти схемы беспрепятственно, перенося контент.
Это, блин, просто киллер мира.
Сюда я перенес сайтмэп, сюда я перенес юзерфлоу и создал новую страничку варфреймы.
Эту страничку я копирую правой кнопкой мыши и закидываю агенту.
Вот, в общем, что я и сделал.
И он здесь уже переходит ко второму этапу.
Обрати внимание, что тут он проходит через этап Update Tools.
То есть он не просто сразу начинает что-то там ваять в фигме.
Он проводит аналитику того, какие инструменты мне доступны, что я могу использовать для этих конкретных задач.
И уже потом двигается.
Это вот подход, прописанный в нашей директиве прежде.
И в целом свойственный агентам, что, конечно, каждый раз радует.
Итак, он здесь проверяет авторизацию, заходит в мою фигму, проверяет, что все работает.
Все.
Создает секцию, двигается дальше.
Короче, весь процесс тут не обязательно описывать.
Вот, например, кстати, еще показательно.
Часто это отмечаю.
Он создал какой-то варфрейм, он сделал скриншот, убедился, что все good.
Вот тут ничего не появилось.
Несмотря на то, что он вроде как что-то создавал.
Он такой, что-то не так.
И двигается дальше, пока не будет приличного результата.
Тут у нас опять что-то не создалось.
В общем, без нашего участия он там прошел все 9 кругов ада.
И в конечном итоге выдал нам варфреймы.
Давайте теперь к самому интересному, что мы получили.
Я напомню, что у меня сервис аренды серверов, какие-то облачные хранилища и так далее.
И, ну, тут есть определенная специфика.
Это некий дашборд.
Что мы уже сейчас видим?
У нас все собрано аккуратно, собрано в соответствии с нашим PRD, с тем, что мы определили ключевым.
То есть, структура у нас все соответствует.
Крайне приятно видеть, что все у нас здесь собрано на автолейаутах.
Да, вот тут у нас разные кнопки.
Там они наверняка будут разных уровней и так далее.
У нас нет высокой детализации.
Этим и отличается варфрейм.
Мы собрали его быстро, собрали достаточно много экранов и в плане структурности собрали детализированное.
Дальше, следующий экран у нас создание сервиса.
Выбираем, какую использовать операционную систему.
Какой регион мы можем выбрать.
Тариф с H-ключами, серверы и так далее.
Это все соответствует действительно специфике серверов, их аренды.
Я лично этим пользуюсь.
Тут у нас есть какой-то тотал.
Двигаемся дальше.
Что у нас еще?
Таб-обзор.
То есть, мониторинг наших серверов.
Как у нас что работает.
Какая у нас загрузка.
Вернее, какая у нас загрузка по конкретному серверу, который мы открыли.
Все, в принципе, тоже структурно.
Я пока не вижу здесь белых дыр.
Выглядит вообще отлично.
Дальше.
На странице пополнения баланса.
Здесь вот, да, по отступам, может быть, не очень аккуратно получается.
Тут у нас вот фиксированная высота.
И на самом деле, часто этим грешит он.
Ставит фиксированную высоту.
Иногда делает эту высоту вообще ноль.
А вот здесь, например, когда я только...
Вот здесь, например, когда только появился этот Warframe, я уже чуть-чуть поправил.
Вот конкретно этот блок.
Он выглядел вот так.
То есть, почему-то тут была фиксированная высота.
Я поставил хак.
И благодаря тому, что все на автолейаутах, проблем с этим никаких нет.
Это быстро, максимально правится.
Ну и тут у нас аналогично.
Он поставил фиксированную 80.
Ставим хак.
Все, отступы у нас уже адекватные и аккуратные.
Вот так же здесь.
Ну, в общем, грешит он тем, что ставит фиксированные размеры.
Но правится это крайне быстро.
Тут, например, у нас есть страница детализации.
Есть, ну, разные элементы управления.
Да, модалки, о которых я ранее говорил.
Есть возможность удалить, переустановить операционную систему сразу с выбором,
какой из, и не с какими-то рандомными текстами,
а нормальными, которые соответствуют действительно существующим операционным системам.
Вот.
Так же модалка с перезагрузкой сервера.
Ну, тоже ее здесь структурно можно поправить.
Как-нибудь там, не знаю, например.
Я хочу, чтобы тут был автоотступ, на самом деле, до самого низа.
И вот так это выглядело хотя бы.
Вот.
В общем, варфреймы наши готовы.
Можно их продолжать детализировать.
Тут вот у нас опять еще хак-контент не сработал.
Ну, да, мелочи такие есть, но с этим уже можно работать.
И таких экранов он вам может собрать какое угодно количество.
Мы могли бы сразу сказать ему, чувак, собери дизайн-систему и сразу на ней макеты.
Было бы красиво, но потом править это проблематично.
Сейчас нам лучше структурно это все отобразить, поправить где-то что-то, поменять.
Проверить, насколько это действительно жизнеспособно.
И затем уже двигаться дальше.
Все те изменения структурные, которые вы вносите, вы точно так же спокойно можете агенту передать.
Либо просто выбрав здесь вот этот фрейм, с которым вы взаимодействовали, перекинув ему и сказав,
я поменял это структурно, мне вот не нравился предыдущий вариант, я изменил это.
Он это внесет во все остальные, не знаю, все возможные документы, сайтмэпы и так далее.
Имейте в виду, что знания агента и то, что у вас там в Figma или в Prode, они должны быть синхронизированы.
То есть, если вы без его участия что-то меняете, не забудьте об этом сообщить.
Потому что на данный момент автоматизировать это невозможно.
Ну и точно так же в среде, если что-то поменялось, мы можем внести эти изменения и его попросить отразить их на варфрейме.
Он это сделает запросто, сразу поймет, где и с чем нужно работать.
Если мы хотим полностью себя обезопасить, ну на этот конкретный фрейм просто закидываем ему ссылку.
Итак, небольшое отступление.
Вот, основную часть этого урока мы посмотрели, разобрались, как мы будем работать в реальном проекте.
Теперь давай сделаем небольшое отступление.
Не всегда мы работаем с продуктом, не всегда нам нужна максимальная детализация.
Иногда достаточно просто чего-то жизнеспособного и вроде как красивого.
Поэтому сделаем отступление и добавим короткий блок про инструмент, который в основной рельс модуля не входит, но хорошо дополняет его в конкретной ситуации.
Поговорим мы о сервисе от гугла, который называется Stitch.
Давай сразу разделим два инструмента по назначению.
Это то, над чем мы работали весь урок.
Это основательный повторяемый флоу для полноценного продукта.
Сайтмап, варфрейм, дизайн-система, финальные экраны, PRD, аудит.
И все у тебя в одной среде.
Все постоянно дополняется, расширяется и формирует общий контекст.
Это мы уже знаем.
Когда мы проектируем продукт, с которым команда будет жить месяцами, который будет развиваться и требует основательного подхода, мы идем, конечно, этим путем.
Google Stitch решает другую задачу.
Это быстрый способ получить пачку правдоподобных Hi-Fi экранов не просто варфреймов, а готовые визуальные макапы с примерным интерфейсом.
И это может быть полезно в разных случаях.
Например, показать команде направление одним скриншотом или сразу паком экранов.
Оттолкнуться от чего-то при проработке финального дизайна или увидеть, как может выглядеть визуализация каких-нибудь данных на дашборде.
То есть зачастую приходится работать со специфичными данными, специфичными отраслями и ты не можешь быть просто специалистом во всем.
Поэтому иногда хочется просто увидеть какую-то визуализацию, как это может выглядеть.
В таких случаях, конечно, можем работать с нашими конкурентами.
Но почему бы не использовать Google Stitch, если эти визуализации можно получить на своих собственных данных и в своем собственном контексте.
Итак, прежде чем пойти в Stitch, что я сделал?
Здесь у меня в среде уже отражено все, что только может быть.
Ну и у вас, соответственно, тоже.
Я попросил его просто сформировать для Google Stitch мне промпт для сборки 16 экранов.
Да, 16 это дофига.
И сделал это он на самом деле достаточно быстро.
Там минут 10, наверное, у него ушло.
Давайте посмотрим, что он нам наваял.
Прежде чем перейдем уже к финальному результату, давайте вообще ознакомимся с тем, как это все дело выглядит.
Из чего здесь начинать?
Ну, во-первых, по сути, ты просто здесь описываешь идею своего продукта, что тебе нужно визуализировать.
И он это делает.
Тут ты можешь выбрать это приложение для мобильного устройства, либо веб-приложение.
Также здесь есть дизайн-системы.
Ты можешь импортировать либо с уже существующего сайта, либо закинуть свой MD-файлик, который будет называться DesignMD.
То есть, предположим, у нас в среде уже есть какая-то дизайн-система.
Мы можем попросить ее сформировать такой файлик, DesignMD, в котором кратко все нюансы этой системы будут описаны.
И сюда его закинуть в качестве промпта.
Он будет работать уже в нашей дизайн-системе.
Но, сразу предупреждаю, тут дизайн-системы как бы очень поверхностно представлены.
В Cloud Design это выглядит намного лучше.
Его мы чуть позже будем разбирать.
А пока можем двигаться дальше.
Сюда также можно присылать ссылки на уже существующие сайты, либо какие-то файлы.
Это твои MD-файлики с описанием структуры.
Это какие-то изображения референсов.
Тоже советую это делать.
Он, в принципе, может усваивать визуал.
Но, сразу говорю, ждать от него какого-то там запредельного визуала точно не стоит.
Также тут есть лайф-режим.
То есть, режим голосового ассистента.
Можно голосом с ним общаться, обсуждать.
Что ты хочешь добавить.
Кому-то так будет удобнее.
Я этим не пользуюсь.
И также модели.
Flash-модель.
Это модель быстрая.
Он максимально быстро все собирает.
Но, я думаю, ты понимаешь, что и качество будет соответствующее.
Syncing Viz 3.1 Pro это самая глубокая проработка.
Редизайн служит для того, чтобы уже существующие приложения или сайты редизайнить.
Но, честно говоря, у меня ни разу ничего толкового с этим режимом не получалось.
И также режим Ideate.
То есть, генерация идеи для того, чтобы решать какие-то проблемы.
Может быть, создавать новые вариации экранов.
Смысла в нем не вижу.
Для меня 3.1 Pro работает лучше, глубже и лучше.
Я немножко подожду, чем потом буду работать с посредственным результатом.
Вот.
Итак, то, что мне сгенерировал мой агент, вот этот prompt для Stitch, сразу скажу.
Я просто ему сказал, сделай prompt для Stitch на основании всех наших данных.
Я никак конкретно его не формулировал.
Я сюда закинул.
И давайте посмотрим, что у нас получилось.
Итак, он выбрал какую-то там случайную дизайн-систему из своей библиотеки.
Немножко ее поправил и сразу здесь визуализировал, как она может выглядеть.
Если мы сейчас откроем дизайн-системы, то увидим вообще, из чего они состоят.
Здесь конкретно в Google Stitch.
Ну, в целом, это все, что тут есть.
Скругление углов, шрифты для заголовков текста и каких-то там тегов.
Основная цветовая палитра и цвет, основной от которого отталкивается он при генерации этой дизайн-системы.
Это вот все те параметры, которые ты тут можешь править.
Есть еще дизайн-мдем.
Здесь более подробно все это дело описано.
И здесь именно текстовые описания можно править.
Можно делать это также через агента, но по большому счету не слишком хорошо дизайн-систему описывает вот такой формат.
Можно добиться результата получше, но многого я бы не ждал.
Итак, вот наши 16 экранов и еще 3 дополнительных.
То есть, получается, 19 экранов.
Давайте посмотрим, что у нас здесь есть.
По сути, весь основной вот этот флоу первого уровня он собрал.
Это создание аккаунта.
Но, как видишь, здесь шрифт немножко отвалился.
Это лендинг-страница посадочная с какой-то краткой информацией.
То есть, собрано в целом аккуратно, не так, чтобы прям уж вырви глаз.
Но, да, это не профессиональный какой-то впечатляющий уровень.
Тем не менее, за 15 минут такое количество экранов стоит отдать должное.
Отдельно экран входа в систему.
Он здесь уже немножко визуально отличается.
Проверка почты.
Также модалка по стилистике отличается.
Но, в общем-то, это уже хоть как-то выглядит и хоть как-то работает.
Дальше.
Что у нас есть?
У нас есть дашборд.
Текущий баланс.
Активные сервера.
То есть, тут уже в каком-то виде визуализируется вот эта сложная информация,
сложная специфика проекта.
От этого можно отталкиваться, в принципе, в своем понимании того,
что мы в рамках этого проекта делаем и как это хотя бы гипотетически должно выглядеть.
Но, опять же, вот здесь вот этот сайдбар, он отличается уже буквально на следующем экране.
Например, тут активность отмечена справа, вот этим бордером.
А здесь на следующем экране уже слева.
Дальше.
Дашборд.
У вас пока нет серверов.
Как выглядит страница с серверами, визуализация каких-то графиков.
Тут у нас уже данные.
Тут у нас уже текстом все соответствует.
Мы можем перейти на наши варфреймы и увидеть, что сходство тут такое достаточно приличное.
И в дальнейшем при разработке решений это может нам помочь.
Дальше.
Здесь у нас есть Ubuntu, Demian, выбор серверов точно так же, их размер, аутентификация через ключ и так далее.
Опять же, все это реализовано, но снова сайдбар уже третьего какого-то вида, если не четвертого.
Далее у нас тут модальные окна, пополнение.
Тут оно, в принципе, даже как-то поинтереснее реализовано, чем на наших варфреймах, собранных через клод.
Ождание подтверждения, история операций, настройки профиля, добавление SSH ключа, мониторинг и 404 страницы.
В общем, за 15 минут по одному промпту быстренько вот так вот сгенерировать такое количество экранов неплохо.
Особенно неплохо, учитывая, что у Stitch тоже появился MCP.
И теперь в клод мы можем закинуть через MCP весь этот результат и попросить его все это дело сверстать уже в готовом виде в рабочем прототипе.
Этим, конечно, мы будем заниматься на последнем модуле, но просто сразу эту возможность я обозначу.
Также смотри, что здесь принципиально отличает в подходе этот инструмент.
Как мы уже поняли, это не полноценная сборка в конкретной дизайн-системе продукты идеально с нуля.
Нет, он достаточно поверхностно работает, он в плане системности, вот нашего UI, достаточно поверхностный.
Он меняет то, как выглядят модалки, как выглядят сайтбары и еще куча всего другого.
Но в качестве первой итерации, визуализации он подходит.
И более того, что здесь особенно мне нравится.
В этом инструменте мы можем генерировать новые итерации экранов, их разные вариации.
Вот, например, есть ожидание подтверждения, да.
Здесь у нас ваш платеж обрабатывается сетью, это может занять несколько минут.
И тут вот кнопка обновить статус.
Ну, это не очень удобно, что пользователь будет сидеть, тыкать, обновить статус.
Я, например, хочу посмотреть, как этот блок может выглядеть в случае, если у нас real-time в режиме реального времени будет отображаться статус.
Поэтому я выбираю этот экран, здесь тыкаю на вариации, ставлю, что их должно быть три.
В формате real-time, сразу тут у нас 3x, то есть будет три разных варианта исполнения этого промпта.
И, ну, я это уже сделал, чтобы не ждать.
Вот, сразу он три варианта нам предлагает.
Первый, это вот такая этапность с зелеными галочками.
С чего мы ждем, на каком мы этапе, это важно для пользователя, мы знаем по эвристикам Нельсона.
Здесь вот он учитывает эту специфику, что да, при оплате криптой нам нужно несколько этапов подтверждения.
И здесь без какого-то там дополнительного согласования и погружения его в тематику крипты мною в контекст, он сам знает, что да, такой механизм есть и он его визуализирует.
Это также очень удобно для вот этих самых первых итераций, чтобы сразу увидеть какие-то моменты, которые ты сейчас вот так вот сразу сходу вспомнить не можешь.
Дальше другой вариант, через колесо ожидания подтверждений, также 6 из 12 шагов пройдено.
Ну и третий вариант, уже поскромнее, без там каких-то зеленых галочек с меньшим количеством пунктов.
Но тут видим, да, что выравнивание у нас немного страдает.
Короче, это не истинно последней инстанции, да, ты сразу не заберешь это и не кинешь в рот и скажешь, вот, ваш продукт готов.
Но, тем не менее, мы уже понимаем, для чего это можно использовать.
Для итеративного подхода, для создания разных вариаций, без необходимости самому что-то там пересобирать, проводить дополнительные исследования.
Это очень удобно.
Также, какие у нас здесь есть возможности для экспорта?
Ну, во-первых, да, это может быть скот, это может быть передача в Google AI Studio, где она тоже там на вайп кодит тебе приложение, но далеко не так хорошо, как Клод.
Экспорт в zip, формирование это в качестве промпта и так далее.
Здесь нас интересует экспорт в Figma, да, то есть будет полезно это конвертировать, но обрати внимание, что тут тоже есть свои нюансы.
Нажимаем конвертировать.
Он преобразует этот блок, который сейчас собран на просто HTML, то есть как веб-страница.
Нажимаем копировать, возвращаемся в Figma, открываем наш workspace и через Ctrl-V вставляем.
Экран вставляется, в принципе все текста у нас ровные, аккуратные.
Он старается придерживаться автолейаута, но не везде у него это получается.
В целом, почему бы и нет, да, неплохо для первой итерации от этого можно отталкиваться и как-то эти экраны потом дорабатывать.
Но имей в виду, что срабатывает это тоже иногда через раз, то есть вместо нормального текста у тебя могут быть какие-то иероглифы и прочее.
Тут просто этот экспорт нужно делать повторно.
Но, к сожалению, это свойственно для огромного количества сервисов от Google.
Они дают очень много возможностей, они всеобъемлющие, они крутые, но они лагают.
Они беспрецедентны по соотношению цена-возможности, но, к сожалению, они не всегда стабильно работают.
Итак, возвращаемся на наши рельсы продуктового полноценного подхода.
И давайте еще немного поговорим о том, при работе через Figma MCP, какие у нас артефакты, какие проблемы могут возникать с агентом.
Итак, во-первых, слишком подробный Warframe.
Да, в директиве уже указано, чтобы такого не происходило, что ты разрабатываешь именно Warframe, не нужно слишком углубляться в детализацию, но, тем не менее, могут возникнуть артефакты.
Что мы делаем в таком случае?
Он не создает все экраны разом.
Он делает это последовательно, постепенно.
Первый, потом второй, третий и так далее.
И уже на этом этапе, пока он думает, мы можем зайти в Figma и посмотреть, какой экран сейчас создается, насколько он аккуратно создан, какая у него детализация и так далее.
И, возможно, сразу его остановить, сказать, чувак, ты делаешь что-то не то.
Сомневаюсь, что такое будет, но лишним не будет за ним присматривать, учитывая, что токены нам достаются не бесплатно.
Вот.
Текста заглушки, то есть Lorem Ipsum везде.
У нас уже есть PRD, у нас есть конкретная специфика, у нас есть контекст.
Он должен нормальные текста вставлять, которые будут отражать действительность.
Если он этого не делает, что-то пошло не так, обязательно ему об этом сообщи и запусти заново.
Такого быть не должно, в директиве это прописано.
Далее.
Автолайяут ломается.
Мы уже сами убедились, да, что автолайяут он в принципе-то хорошо собирает, но почему-то с высотой у него очень часто возникают проблемы.
Либо он делает высоту элементов 0, либо просто любого другого фиксированного значения.
Ставим хак и двигаемся дальше.
Ну, справится это максимально быстро.
И следующая, последняя проблема, это когда у нас формат экрана не совпадает с нашими требованиями.
Крайне редко тоже такое происходит, но стоит за этим следить.
Итак, что мы делаем в качестве домашнего задания?
Как я и говорил ранее, не будем прям рисовать вообще все свои экраны, делать это максимально детально, с какими-то модалками и так далее.
Скорее всего, ты проходишь несколько уроков в день и сжечь сразу все лимиты будет не очень прикольно.
Итак, первое.
Тебе нужно выбрать 2-3 экрана.
Ну, используя директивы, тебе поможет это сделать агент.
Он предложит то, что точно должно быть в MVP, то, что является основным.
Поэтому это ты сделаешь уже с ним.
Двух-трех экранов будет более чем достаточно.
На двух можно даже остановиться.
Вот.
Ну, выбираем, разумеется, с core-приоритетом, то есть то, что должно войти в ядро того продукта.
Опять же, тебе такие предложит агент, когда ты запустишь директиву.
Далее, прогоняем директиву.
Он будет тебе присылать на approve все структуры, все последовательности действий и так далее.
Читаем, ознакомливаемся, принимаем.
После чего закидываем ему ссылочку на figma-файл, в котором мы будем работать.
Он это все там собирает.
И в конечном итоге, что тебе нужно знать в качестве домашки, просто ссылку на этот самый figma-файл, в котором будут уже твои варфреймы.
Их можно будет посмотреть.
И отдельно отмечу, не забудь сделать ссылку публичной, чтобы я смог посмотреть твою домашку.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.